وفي اخر التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا افاد تيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه باستمرار القتال بين قواتها
والقوات الروسيه في خرسون وعلى اطراف
مقاطعه نيكولايز الجنوبيه البلاد حيث تجدد
القصف على محطات المياه في اوتشاكووف
امس
19- على مواقع مركز القوات الروسيه
واستهدف منظومه صاروخيه مضاد للطائرات
مراكز تحكم والسيطره واهداف اخرى
تم القوات الروسيه بتوجيه 30 غاره على
مواقع قواتها كما شلت اكثر من 35 هجوما
صاروخيا على مناطق ماهوله بالسكان عند
خطوط التماس
صاروخان
تحتيه والصناعيه من جهتها قال السلطات
منطقه الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه ان الروس قصف
المنطقه فجرا باكثر من 40 وظيفه مدفعيه
استهدفت مواقع سكنيه فارغه
وفي دنياك ذكرت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
انها صدت عده محاولات روسيه للتقدم في
دنيازك ولجانس
صاروخيه روسيه استهدفت البنيه تحتيه في
مقاطعه ايدونيسكو وخارجه
ان القوات بلاده لا تبعد سوى عده
كيلومترات عن مدينه كريمينا كما انها
تتقدم في اتجاه مدينه سباته
ذكرت شركه الكهرباء الاوكرانيه الخاصه
جيشيك ان نحو 40% من شبكه الكهرباء في
البلاد ما زال معطلا بسبب الضربات الروسيه
على البنيه التحتيه للطاقه على مدى
اسبوعها لتوفير الكهرباء في كل منزل في
قياس مره او مرتين على الاقل يوميا
دنيا
استهدفت مركز الاداره المحليه وادت الى
مقتل احد افراد الشرطه المحليه